all right now I want to tell you about
some of the remarkable people that we
have lost to the corona virus pandemic
this is something we've been doing for
the last few weeks while some were known
to the world
others were known only to loved ones but
they all made a significant difference
here are just some of the many lives to
remember Alan Davi oh the
cinematographer who made his
breakthrough with ET the
extra-terrestrial was known as a master
of light seeing color TV at age 12 Davi
Oh said started my fascination with the
technology of light and photography
early on he met a young Steven Spielberg
who hired him as cinematographer for ET
the color purple and Empire of the Sun
you have to be able to take chances for
chance to find you da vo would earn five
Oscar nominations his warmth and
humanity were as powerful as his lens
Spielberg said he was a singular talent
and a beautiful human being
Allen da vo was 77 character actor Alan
Garfield was a constant presence in 70s
films like the conversation and the
candidate he says what he wants now I
say what I born Alan Gore with's
he started out as a reporter and Golden
Gloves boxer
I thought I was either gonna be the
first boxer journalist you know like a
Hemingway character I'd be like the
Jewish Hemingway right but then he fell
in love with acting and made a career of
playing nervous characters Alan Garfield
was 80
Lila Fenwick was the first black woman
to graduate from Harvard Law School in
1956 once she got the opportunity she
was going to make the most of it said
Harvard Law Professor David Wilkins
Fenwick became an officer in the United
Nations Human Rights Division a
specialist in non-discrimination the
Lila I knew absolutely had to have a
backbone of steel said professor
Patricia Williams a friend and fellow
Harvard Law graduate
she was sparing with words but every
word was either funny or wise Lila
Fenwick was 87 Mario araújo was the
first member of the Chicago Fire
Department to die of coronavirus araújo
joined the department in 2003 and spent
most of his career on truck 25 I went to
one of my worst fires with him and he
was aces John kataoka said he'd go
through a brick wall for you araújo came
to the US with his family from El
Salvador at age six we all supported him
being a firefighter because he wanted to
help people said his cousin Christina
and that made us happy too
hundreds of firefighters escorted his
body to the cemetery
[Music]
mário araújo was 49 lanique of Arc's
dale was a queen in Detroit's ballroom
dancing world nikki as she was known
worked as a bartender drove her lifts
and cared for her four kids but ballroom
was her life said her brother Omari when
she was on the dance floor
she just float everyone loved her her
cousin MoMA nard said paradise gained an
angel I know she's dancing up there
lanique a Barksdale was 47
Carolyn Martin's rights was a graphic
designer
a talented artist who loved to paint but
her number one passion was her son
Thomas Martin's who had Down syndrome
Thomas loved everything and everyone
said his stepfather Rudy writes his
mother was devoted to his happiness near
the end of March both started struggling
with coronavirus Carolyn lost her battle
March 28th nine days later Thomas died
on his birthday
Thomas Martin's was 30 Carolyn Martin's
rights was 55
[Music]
we also lost one of our own this week
John Lane had a 45 year career in print
and broadcast journalism he worked at
the Chicago Daily News where his father
was city editor
he became the Chicago bureau chief for
CBS News and in the 70s a senior
producer for the CBS Evening News with
Walter Cronkite
John was a consummate journalist former
CBS News producer Brian Healy said and
probably one of the most decent human
beings I ever met he was a warm people
person his wife Bess June told us he
kept in touch with everyone he knew John
went on to NBC and CNN Jim Conner who
worked with him there said he was a
person of such enormous faith he would
always find a positive in something even
when there wasn't very much positive and
CBS News president susan Zorinsky said
John Lane was a teacher of our craft on
the road he might get a little loud when
giving you feedback but he was so ready
and willing to help you along the path
he made journalism more than a job he
made it a calling John Lane was 89 Gail
yeah John Lane makes it a very personal
story for us once again here at CBS but
the thing I so liked about your piece
Anthony that you do every Friday it's
just such a reminder of how this disease
operates I mean when you look at the
ages of the people that we've lost and
you look at the ethnicity of the people
that we've lost and the the sexes of the
people of the gender of the people that
we lost it really does not discriminate
and it's such a reminder of how we
really do have to follow the rules those
pieces touch me every single week I
think it's so important that we do to
remind that there are people behind
these numbers that we report on every
day yeah yeah there's enormous human
cost every life lost is worth
remembering we continue to tell these
stories on our broadcast and social
media platforms if you want us to share
the story of someone close to you please
tell us you can email coronavirus at CBS
news.com